do you smoke not
cigarettes you burn pretty easily you
probably had to Sun protect and I see
some freckles on your face so those are
from you know Burns and things like that
are you prone to get red when you drink
something alcohol oh when I drink no but
like when I'm out in the sun for a while
yeah just like red red you probably do a
simple cleanse in the morning and you
style the hair and brush through the
beard nice beard balm hopefully SPF
because you know better yes so recently
I've started using uh joip oil oroba oil
hoba oil yeah and so that's the thing
that I use for my beard and my hair is
it just like in the morning just the
whole shebang if I'm concerned and I
have a particularly young patient who
has eczema and I'm worried about them
developing a food allergy I would say
well maybe just use Vaseline maybe just
use vany cream maybe just use mineral
oil